authors every weekend
book tv television for serious readers
emily radakowski is here tonight to
celebrate a debut collection of essays
that examines her own multifaceted
identity
a world model with tens of millions of
followers
she is a household name for her looks
and prolific image but refuses to let
having a body people want to sell force
her into two-dimensionality
my body tackles fame love
friendship and betrayal and the
intricate web of sexuality and power
feeling small one second and powerful
the next both in and out of control
in reckoning with a level of success
that has brought her both pain and
pleasure emily investigates her own
evolving beliefs the perverse dynamics
of a culture that commodifies the female
body and the dichotomy between who she
is and how she's perceived
emily ratakowski is in conversation this
evening with hannah rosen the editorial
director for audio at new york magazine
where the cut first published emily's
essay buying myself back which was the
magazine's most read piece of the year
previously hannah was the co-host of
npr's invisibilia
she is the author of the book the end of
men and has also written for the
atlantic the washington post and the new
yorker among others
later in the program we'd love to hear
your questions and you'll be invited to
line up at the standing microphones in
either aisle
following the event signed books will be
for sale in the main lobby
thank you all again both here and at
home for being with us tonight and
please join me in giving a warm welcome
to emily rodakowski and hannah rosen
[Applause]
hi everyone
thank you so much for being here
i have to like bask in the weirdness of
this moment for one second of being live
and having people live hi everyone
people are here
so exciting
thank you for coming to washington
um
thank you for having me thank you for
being here yeah i feel um
this book is so personal
that i was thinking like if i just dive
right in i it'll be two therapy session
so
so like that the construct i came up
with is like i'm oprah and you're adele
can we do that wow
i didn't get to watch it so i feel
behind but um i'm i'm a quick learner
hopefully i can yeah we can do justice
to adele and oprah oh my god yeah we can
do it we'll do our best at six and i so
you call the book my body which i feel
like
embodies the thing about the book it's
like in my head the title is like look
at my body stop looking at my body like
it has like you're almost asking people
to sort of come into the conversation
right away is that your intention like
you could have just called it emily's
life or something well that doesn't
sound
like pride and prejudice i'm gonna be
honest with you well um
yeah i mean i definitely think that
there was a part of me that liked
playing with the idea of people thinking
like rolling their eyes and being like
oh emily ratakowski wrote a book called
my body like right and then using that
preconception hopefully
to you know maybe make them buy the book
or even help you know sort of the ideas
in the book be more impactful
um so it was you know uh
i knew what i was doing i knew i was
embracing something that um
was gonna
potentially annoy people
yeah good okay i'm all for that
um
there's a whole section of the book that
in my head i think of is like the
miseducation of emily or like the
signals basically that you received
um and i want to talk about that like
even in your teenage life the
interesting thing about that part of the
book to me was normally when people are
going through puberty or preteens
it's like the signals that come from
inside that are confusing to you but i
feel like in your case even before you
were conscious of it it's all the stuff
that
it was like the cues that came from
outside to you can you talk about that a
little bit like the first time you
realized that or not necessarily the
first time that your body was a thing
and the people started to send that
signal to you from outside yeah um
i mean i think that
i developed really young and i had a
woman's body before i even understood or
knew what sex was um
so it put me in a really
strange position one of the first essays
i ever published was something called
baby woman because i was truly a baby
but i was perceived
now i look back at pictures and i'm like
really people thought i was an adult um
i looked like a child but i did look
older
and i certainly
i started to kind of have this
experience of both
um feeling
really self-aware in a positive and also
in a negative way um so you know at
middle in my middle school feeling
the you know attention that i got from
boys which means that meant that the you
know popular girls wanted to be friends
with me and thinking like oh that's a
good thing um but then also you know
feeling um like i had a vice principal
snap my bra strap or i know i always
remember that yeah that image sticks in
my head of like
that sucks she was a woman um
interestingly i don't think i specify
that in the book um but
you know what's the point like what are
you supposed to do in her mind it was i
mean and this is really kind of that
essay in general beauty lessons um you
know i'm interested in exploring the
ways that
women try to protect other women
by kind of teaching them the hard way or
teaching them about the world and the
way that their beauty and their
sexuality and their bodies are going to
be consumed um
and i think that for example that
vice principal sort of thought she was
saying to me like you should watch out
you should be aware of this and like if
i don't snap your bra strap somebody
else will kind of thing i think you know
i don't think she was doing it
necessarily in a malicious way i don't
know um
but i mean in general
that was sort of the purpose behind that
essay um
i had an ex-boyfriend whose mom
was like a very cool lady um and she
only had a son and at one point we were
talking about if she had had a daughter
and she said well i would have like
obviously made sure that she
you know stayed thin and i like almost
spit up my lunch because i was like wait
what like you're a smart lady with cool
politics and you're talking about how
you would make sure your daughter stays
then like that's you come on you must
know that that's like a recipe for an
eating disorder um and i realized that
in her mind it was
her it was her thinking that would be
protecting her daughter and ensuring her
daughter a good future and love because
then women are loved more
um but your own parents i feel like
there's a lot there's weird mixed
messages in there that there's like a
thing that sticks in my head that your
dad said to your mom mm-hmm when people
complimented on her on her beauty
yeah her father not much it was her
fault yes can you say what he would say
yeah so that's part of um why i included
that in the essay um my grandfather
would say to my mother um you know you
shouldn't say thank you when someone
compliments you on the way you look
because you've done nothing to deserve
it and he was a really serious person
and i think that he um made her feel
ashamed for
the way she looked and
you know her body particularly and it
was a source of shame for her and her
family which is why i think in some ways
she took the other route of like
celebrate your beauty you know old voice
looking at you um whatever and kind of
saying like this should be a source of
pride but in a lot of ways it made me
very aware of the way i was perceived
and you know i write about this in that
essay
like praying for beauty when i was
very young like six and
and what did you think it was like was
it a source of power well i mean just to
be clear yes it was definitely a source
of power like this wasn't just in my
family it was also you know i grew up in
the early aughts and the age of like the
most powerful women to me were britney
spears and pop stars and beautiful women
um
and not just my generation like my
parents loved older movies we'd watch
like marilyn monroe and some like get
hot and it was like okay so there's men
who can be powerful because they're
presidents or they're comedians or
they're rock stars but to me it seemed
that the most powerful women were always
the ones who were most desired by men
um so i think that as a very young
person instead of praying for like money
or
intelligence or safety like it seemed it
just spoke it said so much to me when i
looked back on that and thought about
like
how did i learn that that should be the
thing that i prayed for and wanted
yeah
um
i i kind of really want to talk about
the blurred lines portion of the book
because i have you re-watched that video
so do you never watch it i re-watched it
when i was writing the essay um what was
your second re-watching i'm curious if
it was the same it's so weird to think
about that and think like that's what
propelled me to fame it's such an odd
moment specific artifact of the culture
you know
yeah i mean i think you know what i
wanted to convey when i wrote the essay
and truly how i feel about it is
i don't feel that connected to it it was
a job that i showed up to for a day
so you know even choosing to write about
it was strange strange for me because so
much of the rest of the book is so
personal and this was definitely a
moment of using you know what that video
and what i represented in the zeitgeist
to sort of give an inside look of of my
experience and my approach to modeling
and the kind of like
power dynamics that were at play on that
on that set um but yeah watching it
again it was like it's not i don't feel
that much because i'm like i just think
about that day of work
um
you know i remember how much i got
remember who i was dating do you know
what i mean like i remember that time in
my life um
but i haven't watched it that many times
so i don't feel i don't like live in the
video right my real you know what i mean
one of the pleasures of the book
everyone out there is um that emily
remembers the like the the treatment
notes from that video they're very
embarrassing
um what were they they were like
trashy something man like it was really
yeah i mean i think it was just an
interesting time because people were
sort of already
you know feminist like beyonce hadn't
you know coined the term or owned the
term feminist yet but there was like
this feminist blogosphere people were
kind of talking about um you know like
okay maybe things in the past haven't
totally been like great for women but
like how can we like how can they be
great for women while still being hot
right you know um
right essentially well the interesting
part which i did not know about that
video is is that the setup
the person setting up the video was
trying to create kind of a good
vibe for you guys it was almost had this
like weird like sisterhood
vibe in the room in the beautiful making
of it yeah i mean i think that another
reason i wanted to write about that
experience is because
you know there are multiple sides to
that to the experience um
it was a female director it was a female
dp
there were tons of young women on props
makeup set design whatever
and for me at the time i think i was 20
21
and i had just been working as a model
which you know i described in the book i
had this really hard-headed kind of like
this is my industry i'm working um i'm a
mannequin like it's not fun it's not
glamorous i'm not going to be a
supermodel i'm saving my money because i
saw what happened in 2008 i graduated
high school in 2009 and i was like i
don't want to like move back into my
parents house and have to take a service
industry job so
yeah i was really scared um
and so modeling felt like this like
cheat sheet essentially this like i also
grew up with you know my mom as a writer
my dad was a painter i always understood
the idea of like you have to have your
day job they were teachers you know so i
was like okay i guess this will be my
day job and then i'll figure out what i
really want to do
um
so yeah all of that was true and when
the video was criticized and people came
to me and sort of
you know
i think there was a certain amount of
pointing fingers and like how dare you
be a part of this you know misogynistic
thing i felt really protective of of the
women that i had liked so much on set
and how much fun i had had on set
compared to like front side back of a
shirt or shooting with some you know
creepy group of guys i was like wait i i
made friends on that video they asked me
how i felt um i that's why i danced the
way i did because i was having fun
um
and did you feel tricked after that or
you felt sincere like that would they i
thought was amazing
i felt sincere i felt also defiant um
which is sort of why
i wasn't saying like also the guys who i
shot it with were kind of [ __ ]
you know because um i felt very
protective of the experience that i had
had with that director and with those
other women and also protective of
i wanted my politics to align with how i
wanted to see myself and feel
um what do you mean by that
i wanted to feel powerful um i didn't
want to feel small i didn't want to feel
like a mannequin i wanted to say look i
worked this system um i like you know
have this commodifiable asset my body
and um i had a great time on set and
like yeah you know what that was maybe
that was even power
um and i think that that i think that's
true of a lot not to go on a separate
tangent but a lot of the the ways that
our beliefs are often about our identity
and how and what we want to how we want
to see and feel about ourselves
um which was why it was so important for
me to also write kind of the full
experience about what it really was like
and you know also inspect why i was
defiant and why it felt so important for
me to
feel powerful as the naked girl in a
music video i mean i think that's the
whole trick of the book is like
something that we see
generally on the surface like we're just
seeing your instagram or we're just
seeing you in the video
we
like the pleasure of the book is that
you get
in you get the internal thoughts of that
like what that experience is like and
that's what's interesting about it but
it's like a heart it's like a hard line
to walk like
they're cause it's not you commodifying
your own body yet like it's not yet
you're just getting paid to show up for
a few hours but
and some and people other people are
telling you you're being objectified but
you're trying to like somehow feel
powerful you know yeah um and irene i
would say that you know my relationship
with instagram at that time actually
felt the same way it was similar to the
ways that i felt about that video and
the environment that was on set which
was that i you know was in control in
some ways um
i you know models in the 90s didn't have
a way of dictating what images they were
putting out
it was just left up to the magazines and
whatever editor and blah blah and i was
like wow i can curate
my identity online myself i can control
that and that felt really good it felt
like
you know it it felt like control
yeah i mean the thing that like is on
the other side of the scale is there are
moments in the book when you realize
oh wait if this is my path to power
money control i'm kind of dependent on
men like the men who want this it's like
their desire i'm playing too so that
what is that realization like how does
that turn to feeling i mean i think
that's the thesis of the blurred lines
essay is sort of realizing
you know that as a young girl in my 20s
which by the way you know obviously my
experience as a model is very specific
it's an industry but i have friends who
look back i mean taylor swift
we should talk about you know
how she feels looking back
at being
my tick tock is all taylor swift and
jake gyllenhaal
um i've been let's talk about it for ten
minutes exactly yeah excess
um
i would love to um
but uh no i mean i think that
a lot of the experience i had as a young
person as a model but also with
interactions in my personal life was
like oh i'm because i'm young and i'm
desirable i'm the one who has the power
and i think that even men felt that way
the men that i was interacting with and
i think actually some of the instances
that i write about in the book they
almost felt like they were like
reclaiming their power by kind of doing
these like disrespectful things because
it felt like oh this young beautiful
girl like she she's the one like she's
actually emasculating me in some way
because she has the power here because
she's desired
um even though now i look back and i'm
like oh i was actually so young um i was
a kid and you were an adult
and you know the situation was the power
dynamic was very different than what i
thought um and so yeah that's sort of
part of the revelation of blurred lines
and and charting my relationship to that
video my memory of that video and um
how it's also you know representative of
the evolution of my politics
that was such a hard end to that
sentence that i was gonna follow you for
a little longer um the uh the um
the one there's a super creepy incident
in the book i mean another thing the
book does is take you into worlds that
most of us don't have access to
and it's kind of like after blurred
lines and a lot of success you end up in
like weird vip situations can you just
tell i mean this is a less well-known
story but the one about um
the 25 000 to show up at a sports game
that's such a weird
story like what is that world and how do
different women behave in that world um
yeah well that essay is called
transactions and an excerpt of it ran in
the guardian so if you read that then
that's the one i'm referencing um
i was really interested in investigating
my own judgment of women and how they
navigate systems of power in regards to
men
um specifically you know in my
you know there i could write a whole
book just about that um called like
victoria's secret girl she's a great
character in the book oh yes yeah she's
a real life person um
but um you know i was interested in i
mean i think people kind of like do that
in their marriage sometimes i have
friends who you know marry somebody
wealthy and whatever there's all kinds
of negotiations but in the industry it's
very specific because um as an unknown
model you're basically you know there's
women who kind of are sent out to
castings
to recruit other young models to
essentially go
out with rich men um and just like stand
with them at a table and like they're
kind of hoping to have sex with you but
like honestly they just want you to like
stand next to them and make them look
cool
um it's funny but it's pretty dark
um and uh
you know it's it's a step away from the
jeffrey epstein kind of world to be
totally honest and um as as now living
in new york city i see i have i don't
really go to night clubs but there's
been a few different moments where i've
watched these like groups of very under
underage very clearly very young women
walk in with like one guy who's the
party promoter and then you know the
wealthy guys kind of join and it's
related also there's celebrity men
there's this whole kind of market around
this and you know as an unknown model
you don't get paid but they essentially
host a dinner so if you're
you know a working model in la and
you're not making that much money you're
hungry straight up
and you go to these things um and they
know what they're doing they're like
come to nobu and you know the whole vibe
is like eat whatever you want drink
whatever you want and
so a lot of models go because they just
want a free meal and then they get a
little drunk and then they're invited to
the club and that's sort of like when
these wealthy men come into play
so
i had experiences with that where you
know i felt extremely uncomfortable as
somebody who
you know had not had was always very um
liked clear transactions and those were
not very clear
and then the the other part of that
essay is an experience i had with the
now fugitive um
joe lowe
malaysian fugitive who
produced and financed the wolf of wall
street
and he was essentially stealing money
from the malaysian people it's pretty
horrible story the malaysian government
um the president was essentially working
with him to help that happen it's great
if you haven't read it there's a book
called i think billion dollar billion
dollar whale or something it's really
crazy
but um you know my manager got a call
like oh and i had just moved into an
apartment in new york that
had bed bugs and like i was totally not
i was living in the east village and it
was
i was new to the world so 25 000 is a
lot of money huge amount of money yes um
and they were like yeah he just wants
you to come to the super bowl and i was
like what do you mean come to the super
bowl and my manager at the time was like
trust me it's cool like jamie foxx will
be there leonardo dicaprio like other
celebs will be how much do you think
they got paid i would love to know
i'd love to know
love snow um i mean i do know that you
know it's public record that like there
were
basquiats that were seized from
you know these actors homes and whatever
that were gifts from jolo um
it's worth it i mean just to show up at
the super bowl yeah well i didn't care
about football so um
did you like cheer at the wrong moment
oh i had no idea what was going on at
all so um i wasn't even pretending and
that was the other really bizarre thing
about these interactions is like you
know you don't actually have to do that
like i wasn't
i wasn't being told to cheer or anything
um but was what was interesting in both
of these experiences was watching how
other women like saw opportunities and
capitalized on them and was like okay
like this guy obviously wants to have
beautiful women around like how can i
parlay this into something larger um and
i think that at a certain point in my
life i was like i would never do that
meanwhile i'm you know doing paid posts
for toothpaste that are owned by the
same type of men essentially um and
maybe the transaction is a little bit
more clear but um that was another
instance of sort of like my own judging
my own internalized misogyny and also um
you know kind of like realizing how how
we all exist on the spectrum of
compromise although there's an
undercurrent of like i i when you say
the transaction's not clear it helps me
understand what was going on your head
because there's a lot of there's like
almost it's not quite violence but it
doesn't feel safe like you don't know
what's going to happen to you you don't
know what's expected of you it's like a
really weird situation to fall into and
the other thing is you can't necessarily
i'm reading into it you can tell me if
this is true or not you can't
necessarily rely on the other women
like it's
it's hard to tell in a lot of the
interactions that happen when you fall
into these situations
are what's the relationship between the
women like are they friends are they
competitive like what how how are they
playing off each other in these
situations yeah um i mean i actually
wanted to write more about the
interactions that i had with the other
women but they were actually quite
limited and i realized it was because we
were sort of focused on the experience
of you know being at this
like
club or whatever or um you know also it
i guess there's a little bit of a thing
of like whose side are you on like um
and
yeah i think that that's something i
mean honestly to me the book is more
about relationships with other women and
other women than it is men um
i at one point wanted to name every
essay after like i mean i basically talk
about my mom you know friend in high
school
famous women what they've had an impact
on me like i
do think that that that could have been
the old title for the book or in some
way
um
you always stop too abruptly for me to
catch up to you um no that's okay i
don't even know i'm doing it um
there's a there's a point i think well i
think it's
i think
this is a risky thing to do in the book
which is to like
like the thing you wrote about your trip
or sort of when you start to
commodify yourself almost and and ask
people it's hard to be sort of rich and
successful and ask people to inhabit
your mind or feel sympathetic that feels
like a risky thing to do
did you ever think about that and like
how people like will they feel sorry for
me no they won't feel sorry for me
because i am rich and or whatever i mean
i didn't write any of the essays like
looking for sympathy i wrote them
because i had questions about my own
existence and my own contradictions in
my own life
that i wanted to explore and maybe try
to come up with some answers but also
just have like
an investigation and a record of that
investigation and an essay but then
people could kind of you know
tell me what they what they think about
these things what are their thoughts
what are their politics what do they
make of these experiences um and like
what does it say about the world we live
in that you can be paid to go on a
vacation and you know like the ways that
i'm kind of trying to take back control
and i mean you know
when you say commodifying yourself it's
like i hear you but at the same time my
experience
from blurred lines to doing that feels
very um like it feels like the same
thing it's like taking a check you know
what do you mean like there's a moment
when you're when i think it feels like
in the book there's a moment when you
actually make the decision like why
would i
why would i put you know why would i
wear a bikini for somebody else's bikini
company i might as well do it for myself
post it on my own instagram and that
feels powerful but that's not like the
end well i think it's just about control
it's about having more control um as a
model and as a commodity um
and using my body in that way but i
don't know
if it release power i mean one of the
questions of the book is sort of like
what is empowerment is it financial
success is it a feeling is it
fulfillment is it fame um
is it in feeling wanted is it in not
feeling wanted um like where what what
does empowerment really mean it's such a
it's a word i hear so much when it comes
to women um especially in pop culture
and in my own experience i'm like wait
can we just go back and like can we
define that
um so that's that's sort of one of the
larger questions in the book
in a weird way the most powerful essay
in the book which everyone talks about
which is the assault that happened to
you when you were younger and then
should we tell that story i never know
how much people know i mean that's the
story that was on the cut yeah we'll
tell it in very brief but it's what's
interesting to me about that story is
it's the most clear like a lot of other
in it
basically well you tell a summary of it
it's weird for me to do it but um but it
is the most like to me that's like a
thing that happened that is so bad that
it would lead you to take control of
your own
body commodity destiny whatever like
it's just so wrong that
yeah i mean at the time um
let's tell the story so we're not like
speaking in inferences yeah there was a
photographer who um shot me when i was
like 19. it was kind of a pretty
uncomfortable situation and then he went
on to publish multiple books using the
images and my my calling like years
later they just show up and he's such an
[ __ ] as it's happening and then like
sorry i mean it's a truly but you know
it's funny that you say that it's so
clearly wrong because at the time um i
you know
first of all i turned to like the legal
system and tried to say okay like what's
my legal protection here and there was
no way that anyone could say this is
wrong and there was no justice there and
then i actually turned to the internet
and tweeted about my experience and how
i didn't want the images to be out there
and also no one
felt like it was wrong
that's a good point that legally like
you signed this release but like you're
you're so i didn't sign the release oh
right that's right yeah i didn't sign
the release um potentially an agent
maybe sold it or it was forged i will
probably never know
um
but i mean yeah no nobody felt that that
was very clear cut when it was happening
um even when i kind of like turned to my
followers and was like hey don't buy
this book whatever everyone was like
no
you took those pictures
um so i didn't feel like it was clear
like that was the essay was clear i
think it was received as such when it
went up
um when it was printed in new york
magazine but i think it was received as
wrong yes people felt very like oh wow
this guy is an [ __ ] and whatever but
it just feels morally outrageous that
someone could essentially like trick a
young person in this completely weird
setup into taking these pictures be
totally dismissive of them
and then years later like when when
they're worth something come back and
publish pictures of you
and make a ton of money off of it not
contact like it's an outrageous
like in your soul it feels so outrageous
that that could happen i mean i hear you
but you know for me that was an
experience i had a ton of shame around i
thought i acted a certain way i didn't
protect myself i wanted to impress him
as he dismissed me i tried even harder
to kind of impress him um i you know i
did take those pictures so
for me it didn't feel clear it still
doesn't feel totally clear-cut i felt
complicit in the situation and i had a
lot of shame around it and also in that
essay i write about paparazzi like the
least relatable thing anyone you know
when i published the essay i was like i
don't think anyone's gonna like this
because i was sure that it was kind of
you know my experience up until that
point was that people had not been
sympathetic with those ex those things
even though they had been out in the
public
which was you know another it was very
encouraging i had already sort of
written about 50 000 words of the book
but i hadn't edited it hadn't kind of
opened and started to edit but it was
really encouraging to have that piece go
out into the world and see that like
writing could be a medium
where you know at least people could
think about the questions that i was
posing in a way you know that i was
communicating something in a way that
you know gave me control i mean i think
writing the book we're talking about
control is an act of control to kind of
try to take back my narrative
yeah it's interesting that you say
you're not looking for sympathy because
i think the reason that essay resonated
so much is because it just feels i guess
it just feels real like you're not
you you put it out there in in all the
circle of internal thoughts that you had
about that situation including feeling
complicit and so it just
even though your experience is extremely
particular it's not like a million
people have had that experience it's
still relatable because everybody's been
in a situation where they feel complicit
or they've looped around or they don't
know if it's their fault or not so
yeah maybe that's why
it was received so well
yeah i mean again i wrote the essay sort
of to lay everything out and to look at
it myself but also to have other people
be able to examine um
like i even say in the book like i'm
gonna proclaim my contradictions you
know um because i i i think you know
it's also a tendency i have of kind of
like overexposure which for better or
worse has led me to have the life i've
had um
but you know
yeah i'm very interested in sort of like
being very honest rather than trying to
make people feel a certain way because
i'm not totally sure how i feel about
all of these things
there's a
there's a romantic moment when you talk
about meeting your husband um
i don't know if i read this correctly
but it's like a moment
when he it's it's maybe it's imp maybe
it's not empowerment i don't really know
it's just romantic but when he comes and
and like
essentially just kind of puts himself
between you and people who feel they
have a right to you can you just like
talk about that moment it's literally
like stop someone from putting it's a
very interesting moment in the context
of the book
yeah um
before we were dating um he was like at
some party that i was um we were both
there and
somebody asked for a picture and like
kind of like put their hand like this
like little finger came over here on
this side
i was don't say that a little drunk yeah
um and i was just like oh whatever you
know and i heard him say like no
touching and the guy like immediately
like dropped his hands and was like oh
i'm so sorry which i would have never
done myself to be honest which i don't
that's probably not a good thing i wish
i was more the type of person to say
that um because i do think as a public
persona and as a woman i sort of feel
like
no i'm like public property in some way
um
i have a complicated feeling around it
um
and
in the past
i had dated men who were very like she's
got this she doesn't need
you know
any interjection and i always thought
that was very respectful
um so
you know i think if you had asked me
before he had done that i would have
said like i don't like it when men like
feel like they have to i can handle the
situation on my own but all of a sudden
i was like oh wow he's interested in
protecting me and using
his relationship in the world like who
he is as a you know cis white male
kind of a big guy to like protect me and
it for lack of a better term was hot
it was hot
um my girlfriend read it and she was
like wow that that part was hot and i
was like
yeah i was um
so
yeah
um i was looking at your instagram
before this event and i was thinking
like almost as an addendum to my body
like the kinds of pictures you've posted
lately
like the pregnant the pregnancy series
the pregnancy baby series the pregnancy
breastfeeding series i was wondering
about the relationship to whether those
were freeing i mean there's like a
beautiful picture of you naked and
pregnant
how does that moment of your life relate
to everything you're writing it's like
your body being used in a totally i mean
there's a few breastfeeding pictures
yeah just
what was that about for you
it was a trip because i was finishing
the book as well um so um i was writing
about my body and there was a moment
where i was like well i can't publish
this book because now i have to write
all about pregnancy and birth because
that's like that's everything um but i
think that'll just have to be another
book
i do write about the birth of my son in
the last essay
i was
curious about how pregnancy was gonna
affect me talk about lack of control um
like you wake up every day and your
body's just doing something completely
different and there's no way to ensure
that you know everything's go you don't
know what's going on like you really
don't and you're just kind of growing
and everything's changing and um
but i found it actually really
i really enjoyed it everybody's
experience with pregnancy is really
different but it actually helped me
appreciate my body
um
trust it
um kind of like let go of control and
say like okay this thing knows this
vessel knows better than me
and i have to sort of
just take the passenger seat and let
that happen
um
so much of my life has been relating to
my body as a tool and
you know a tool to guarantee lovability
as a tool to guarantee financial success
and
i think that you know it didn't feel
like a tool particularly in birth and in
pregnancy because it required me to
let go of managing that tool
it was just
doing something on its own
and then you know
even more so um
in the in
in that last essay really honestly the
biggest moment for me was the bike ride
that i take with my husband and my
friend and just sort of being able to
appreciate my body as a thing that takes
me through life
which is what a body is
which the breastfeeding pictures that i
was particularly thinking about because
it is like your body as a tool
like that many mothers have experienced
but in a totally different way like
nobody's buying it nobody's paying for
it but it has to do work you know
yes um it's sustaining life and that was
um breastfeeding was actually a chunk
that was in that last essay so it's
funny that you're saying that and i took
it out because it didn't work
timing-wise but
there was this really crazy thing i
don't know how many people have had
children or had this experience but
you your breasts wake you up to feed
your child um like they ache and they
hurt and you like i would find myself
like walking like a zombie to meet my
baby to feed my child and it was this
really bizarre experience of like oh i'm
not in control here like there's
there are things at work that have
kept human beings
on the planet and um that's that ancient
machinery is then what was within me and
i have to just
like release control and
see what happens
and trust my body and and the process
um oh sorry um
we we we're gonna open up for questions
everyone in just a few minutes um
i don't know how to ask this question i
was as as i got to the end of the book i
was thinking
you talk a lot about playing the game
like about capitalism playing the game
with your body are you winning or losing
do you feel like you
are winning or losing
great
um i don't know i don't know about the
game i feel like um
what i do have clarity on is
win winning with outside of the game um
by like
doing something as fulfilling as writing
a book
um i don't know if that sort of side
that's definitely a moment where the
actual writing of it is fulfilling it is
weird because most of the time you're
used to just like being look it's like a
surface thing so it must be such
a like a
180 degree turn to be like i'm by myself
nobody's looking at me this is like my
internal i mean i loved it um i love
writing and that
for that partly that reason but nobody
really loves writing you just love that
oh it's like miserable but i love the
oh to be clear yeah miserable yeah um
but um
i think that that like focus and the
like exercise of or the experience of
that is just
um like i don't feel this way about
physical exercise but i know when people
talk about running sometimes and they're
like i hate it but it feels like it's so
satisfying i'm addicted i'm like oh i
understand that in relationship to my
experience with writing
yeah yeah i don't think it would be fair
if you were like i'm beautiful and
writing is so easy for me and it's
totally great and it's like you don't
you don't want to be that writing is so
hard
it's really really so hard
um well congratulations it's really
beautifully written everybody should
read it it is all i mean so many of the
essays are like so
moving and open so many windows into so
many worlds
that are both completely exotic and
totally familiar at the same time so
thank you for doing this totally so we
are going to open up for questions so if
anybody wants to ask questions please
come to the microphone as people are
lining up
i am going to ask questions from our
virtual audience i don't know where the
camera is but hello virtual audience
um
my mom's in the virtual audience and my
nieces um
so from katie in chicago have you heard
of or talked to other models buying back
their photos and what are their
motivations in doing so
i mean so um
this is like i'm in a very particular
position most working models don't have
the ability to do that um or have access
to it i do think that there's more
conversations around
copyright and also you know in the age
of the internet in general like i would
say
that
with revenge porn and with everyone
essentially is kind of like putting
their images out there um i think that
there's a lot of conversations around
ownership that are interesting but
specifically in the modeling industry
no i don't think that there there has
been um
a lot of that that's true like they
can't afford it
they can't afford it um i wanna before i
get to you guys this one question is
really really great um i wanted to ask
about race and public perception how do
you think people reacted to your to
blurred lines as opposed to megan and
cardi b and wap how does sexuality
interact with whiteness ethnic ambiguity
um but it is interesting to think of
like from blurred lines to [ __ ] like
videos i start the book off with [ __ ]
because it was it had come out and i was
like wait this conversation around
sexuality and like empowerment
really in a music video really reminds
me of this but i will say i mean i think
that those women as black women have had
it's so much worse i mean like i like
without a doubt um the racial
stereotypes that come into play it's
insane
um and even though you know it was their
music video and they were in control
they have to battle a whole other
set of issues um that you know
are crazy but it is a similar thing
going on in that video that goes on in
this book which is like am i in control
like i'm doing this thing i'm leaning
into it and maybe that's a form of
empowerment but well i think she does
know cardi b but well no but it was so
interesting because it was like you had
you know really leftist feminists and
right-wing people both saying like this
video's trash
um and like when does that happen in
this country so
yeah
i know they come together and saying
something is crazy i hate on
heartwarming basically yeah
um yes go ahead since you lined up first
thank you sorry
um
as a young woman who is navigating her
career your independence and your
femininity
and not to mention dating
my question is how did you deal with the
heartache and kind of the failures and
rejection especially from an industry
that is so easy and
quick to reject women for kind of
another
yeah
um
i mean i think that this is something
i've i
you might hear me say this again because
i really it was one of the takeaways
that i had with the book i mean i wrote
it to investigate experiences that i had
a lot of shame around and i thought that
i was going to look back at the book and
be like that's the moment that's where i
should have done something different or
that was so stupid or why did you
compromise yourself in this way why did
you agree to do this blah blah blah
whatever um and what i've realized is
that women that's actually a really not
a healthy exercise
and i think that young women need to
learn to give themselves a break and
understand the larger things that are at
play outside of their personal choices
that lead them to those heartaches and
to those brutal kind of realities um
which is you know partly why i wrote the
book is you know i don't just think that
my life has been a product of my choices
it's also the culture and the world that
we live in and i think it's really
important for young women to in
particular to learn to not be so hard on
themselves
oh nice cool
go ahead
i was wondering if people in general or
your followers kind of if their opinions
on you if they started taking you more
seriously
uh changed
after you opened your business or
started your business
no
or like maybe maybe more if they started
taking you more seriously like with all
these stigmatizations and stuff that
you're talking about yeah i mean i
definitely think that you know in the
world of skims and you know kylie lip
[ __ ] there's like a i think that
when people see women taking control of
their image and like using
what has been used by other people to to
have their own hustle people definitely
are like oh wow maybe she's business
savvy whatever um
so yes i think in in some ways um
you know
that has been a part of it but i do you
know the book only came out a week ago
but i'm hoping that the book is maybe
more impactful in that way but also i
shouldn't worry about it so much right
like that that's that's the chance you
do have the true hero friend whoever
your friend is who like helps you build
your business like your actual true
friend of life does show up that's like
a good counter balance to all this other
like
girl-on-girl weirdos yes no i think
female friendships are
hugely important
yes
hi emily thank you so much for coming my
name is iman and i'm a college student
you operate between so many industries
from modeling to entrepreneurship and
now literature
and i was wondering
what advice you would give to young
women in their 20s on owning their
sexuality and entering these
professional spheres and even
overlapping between them as you have
um thank you for coming um
i um i mean i think that
one thing i've learned and this sounds
it's like the kind of thing i got advice
around pregnancy and motherhood and i'd
be like i've heard that a million times
it's not helpful but then you come back
to it you're like oh right that's what
they that was good advice um
i do think that um
trusting your gut and following your
instinct there's you know this
i think that there's a culture of sort
of like
find a mentor like you know people are
gonna guide you and that's true but i
think in particular with young women
there's um
a lot of
mentors will be quick to sort of just
say like you should do it this way and
like don't listen to yourself and
whatever um and can be sort of
dismissive
i have found that taking that advice
from people has not been helpful for me
that instead kind of doing what i want
to do i mean nobody i think would have
said like write a book of essays about
sexuality like that's what that's the
ticket you know but it's something that
i felt passionate about and you know
whether or not it's successful i at
least can go to bed at night knowing
that i did what i cared about um so
trusting your gut awesome thank you so
much thank you
yes
hi emily um thank you so much for
sharing um in the cut your your essay
last september's one greatest thing is
already 20 20. thank you um i guess my
question is you mentioned about like i
guess being considered like public
property about being in control and
trading your instagram about like the
accessibility that you feel like you
have to have to people how do you
navigate that now i mean especially i
notice that you don't share your son
that much in your instagram like i guess
through going through this process of
like getting fame overnight like how do
you control that like how much you're
having to share and how much people
think that they know you because they
see you everywhere
that's a really good question i'm
figuring it out every day um for example
with my son at you know one point i
wasn't sharing his face and then he was
getting paparazzied and that was another
example of me kind of wanting control
and feeling like you know if there's
going to be images of my son i want to
choose which ones are going to be out in
the world
it's not the ideal but it's a you know
it's my way of taking control and also
like
you know it started to feel like more of
a headache to try to protect his image
from being out there than to just like
relax and be like it's okay he's he he
can be out in the world and that feels
better to me
um
i think it's just a day-to-day you know
feeling
gut checks and sort of saying like what
what feels comfortable and even when i
was writing this book deciding what i
wanted to share and why you know
that was kind of just it was my it was
what felt right and you know
being really checking in with myself in
the way that i definitely used to not um
i used to feel like you know i would
never even if somebody touched me
whatever i would never have thought
because i knew you know that they would
think she's rude um now i'm a little bit
more interested in taking care of myself
rather than worrying about the way i'm
perceived
in some ways you're lucky as a writer
because that's like a response to
parasocial relationships it's like here
have it like these are my thoughts this
is what i think about these situations
this is all my complicated feelings it's
like a great way of addressing you know
all the things that people are
projecting on you it's like you don't
have to project you here it is you can
read it you know totally um
yes
uh thank you for coming
um i'm curious now that you're a mom and
a business owner what are your thoughts
on we've seen a couple articles in new
york magazine or the new yorker about
like the fall of the girl boss trope
and
how that sort of like came out of like
grind culture and like women have to
like work 14 hours but then also you
know care to their maternal instincts
and they have children now that you're a
mom like what do you think of that
whole phenomenon where do you see
yourself and all that
yeah um at one point i was like i need
to write a girl boss essay and then i
sort of realized that my girl boss essay
was the essay that you talked about the
maldives um going to this vacation and
sort of
thinking like okay well i might as well
be the one to sell the bathing suits
rather than
this guy um
i mean i think that capitalism is really
rough on everyone and i think that you
know women had this feeling of that's
not that's related to the conversation
i'm interested in having of you know i
have to become the man i have to become
the boss in order to be
viewed as successful so even if that
means being an [ __ ] who like doesn't
pay fair wage that's that's the game i
have to play for and especially as a
woman i have to go doubly hard in order
to be taken seriously and um i think
that was unfortunate because it didn't
mean you know real change
at the same time also was nice to see
some women in businesses and in places
of power that we don't normally see
women um and then i think actually the
backlash to the girl boss phenomenon and
the way that so many women were held
accountable in a way that i don't think
that there were as many men being held
accountable
was also related to sexism
so
thank you we're just going to take three
more questions three
you sure
okay
okay go ahead
all right
hi my name's romeo and thank you for
being here my question is what would men
learn from reading this book
um hi romeo thanks for coming
um you know i
i think that um
i wrote this book with men in mind in
some ways because
there were there are men that i'm close
to who i felt like really didn't
understand why i'd get so emotional or
upset about
any
number of situations um and they'd kind
of be like i mean i get it like it's
hard right
um
and
i i felt like so frustrated that i
wasn't doing a good job of explaining
what it's like to be a young girl or be
a woman in this world and
when i wrote the book i kept
i didn't want it just to be in convert i
obviously was thinking about women a lot
but i wanted it to be accessible to men
so that they could potentially feel
compassionate
and empathetic with what it's like to be
a woman
thank you thanks okay
hi emily hi hi my name is oh that's loud
my name is drew um i just wanted to ask
i see a lot of people
it's hard to tell with math i see a lot
of young people in here
and i'm 23 and all my friends are 23. i
was just wondering like you talk a lot
about control and like being able to or
like feeling out of control
and sometimes like how hard it is to
navigate that i was just wondering for
someone at our age and like starting out
because a lot of the experiences that
you talk about were in your early 20s
what is the best advice that you have
for like
navigating that and really harnessing
that control in different spaces
i mean it's so hard when you're 23
because you're 23 and people are like oh
you're 23 year old woman what do you
know and why would you know even if you
are inserting your your agency like
there's a certain amount of dismissal
and distrust
um
i mean i think being aware
of
i don't want to say the same thing but
of protecting yourself and having a
frame of reference that's not
not letting things land personally
um
that can be helpful and
as you kind of tried to find control
because you're going to get so much
pushback um
but it's it's really tough i don't have
you know i wish that there was some kind
of guidebook to this i think just
knowing yourself and
really trusting your instinct and
reminding yourself that the reactions
that you are getting aren't because of
who you are it's because of the world
and the culture that we exist in
thank you thanks
last question
um hi emily thank you so much for coming
my name is lydia um i finished the book
a couple days ago i loved it oh thank
you um yeah and i especially loved the
chapter called the woozies it definitely
made me a little emotional um and i love
that you talk about the relationship
with your mom because i think you know
the relationship that a woman has with
her mom is such an important aspect of
life
um and so
my question was before writing the book
or before it was published did you ever
sit down with your mom and you know have
these conversations that you talk about
in the book
and if so like how did that go oh thank
you i meant to ask that question i'm
like well what your dad thought of the
book um you know i i shared everything
with my mom and
it's an ongoing conversation
like all intimate close relationships um
i mean i think that
you know
what i tried to do was
really
give her you know
just to be as empathetic like i know
that everything in the book she did out
of love and out of the desire to be
close out of a desire to protect me
um and as a parent myself i like have to
accept that i'm going to be imperfect as
a parent and they're even the most well
intentioned person you know is going
there's going to be things that are
messages that
you know just don't land the way that
you intend them to
um but yeah it's an it's an ongoing
conversation
that is a lot of like peace and wisdom
around a mother relationship
um well thank you emily so much for
coming to dc thank you all for coming
thank you so much
weekends on c-span 2 are an intellectual
feast every saturday